la chasse a rouvert le week end dernier
en val de loire et avec elle un nouveau
débat initié par le sénat l'interdiction
de l'alcool sur les sites de chasse afin
de réduire les accidents qu'en pensent
les premiers concernés on en parle avec
mon invité ce soir bonsoir alain benoit
bonsoir vous êtes président de la
fédération de chasse d'indre et loire
près de 13000 pratiquant un chiffre en
hausse depuis l'an dernier interdire
l'alcool donc une question de sécurité
affirment les sénateurs d'abord pour les
chasseurs qui représente 9 victime sur
dix lors des accidents ensuite pour les
promeneurs pas d'apéro avant ni pendant
la chasse est ce une bonne idée puisque
c'est une bonne idée c'est une évidence
même pour n'a pas attendu les sénateurs
pour faire attention à ce genre de
pratique les consommations d'alcool si
elle existe encore d'un autre de
continuer j'ai tic parce que c'est ça
fait partie d'une belle journée de
chasse mais c'est après la chasse
personne aucun responsable de chasse
prendrait la responsabilité
d'emmener quelqu'un qui aurait été
alcoolisée c'est trop dangereux pour lui
pour sa responsabilité parce que s'il ya
un accident et sera mis en
responsabilité et donc personne ne le
fera vous savez aujourd'hui les
chasseurs s'auto contrôler d'une manière
absolument remarquable redoutable plus
personne peut jouer enfin n'importe quoi
et heureusement et d'ailleurs les
sénateurs le le signal en même temps
qu'il nous dise il faudrait interdire
l'alcool alors qu'il y ait qu il y ait
un rapport un report avec le taux
d'alcoolémie
aujourd'hui les acteurs disent que
l'alcool est responsable dans 9 % des
accidents selon les statistiques les
inscrits
on est déjà sur un taux d'accidentologie
très très faible 1 7 8 accidents mortels
pendant que son 7,8 de troupes mais qui
sont très très faible et une centaines
d'acides résidents 2-6 donc sur des
véhicules des maisons les 9% c'est déjà
trop au 10 les sénateurs êtes d'accord
oui oui ainsi un trop savoir ce qu'il
faut une interdiction de l'alcool loi
donc je crois pas je vois pas pourquoi
la ferai pas les chasseurs qu'on ne
ferait pas pour parce que d'être
stigmatisés encore et encore si c'est
pas fait sa promo stigmatiser chasseurs
ça donne ça donne c'est enfin ça donne
l'impression il faut encore que nos
chasseurs sont à vinay je crois qu'il
parte à la chan
c'est tout sauf ça arrêtons de
stigmatiser c'est ce rapport il aurait
mieux fait de dire qu'ils veulent
interdire la chasse ce serait plus
simple toujours selon ce rapport à plus
des deux tiers des accidents résultent
de faute grave enfreignant les règles
élémentaires de sécurité pourtant la
sécurité 1 c'est le critère numéro un
c'est ce que dit ce rapport aux 6,1 pour
obtenir le permis de chasse comment vous
expliquer qu'il ait encore des certains
dérapages
on a des formations qui sont qui sont
drastiques vous passer votre permis de
chasse aujourd'hui c'est parce que c'est
un examen fait par l'état qui est
quelque chose de très compliqué avait à
faire avoir 30 % d'échec je rentre dans
son échec c'est très bien ça sas a pris
globalement ce qui ce qui peut arriver
un chasseur on lui demande énormément de
choses dans une fraction de seconde on
lui demande de reconnaître
l'animal d'être sûrs de ce qu'ils
veulent c'est quoi il va être tirée on
lui demande de regarder que l'animal est
passé les allées qu'il soit rentré dans
ses angles de 30 degrés degrés cessons
ces angles le non respect de ces angles
qui sont les plus d'action d'une
accidentogène avant de savoir s'il va
pouvoir acheter sa balle donc c'est
énormément de décisions à prendre dans
une fraction de seconde avec un peu
d'adrénaline quand ils marchent bref
donc donc ça peut provoquer ça peut
provoquer un peu de un peu un peu de
stress globalement les chasseurs sont
habitués à ça et le gère très bien mais
le non respect des 30° arrive encore ça
c'est quelque chose de
de commande vous dire savoir qu'il faut
absolument éviter c'est l'automobiliste
qui veut pas que ça me dépasse et me
montre à l'heure où à 50 alors dans le
village passé où on s'en sort pas si
vous n'avez pas de voter un tout dernier
mot et je lui disais treize mille
chasseurs cette année en eure-et-loir y
aura-t-il assez de gibier avec une
sécheresse 2022 record c'est moins d'eau
et de nourriture pour les animaux alors
est ce qu'il ya un effet de cette
sécheresse alors pour ce qui concerne la
petite zone de plaine serrières mais
perdreau le faisan l'ailière globalement
les chasseurs ont apporté de l'eau ont
apporté des compléments pour que ça se
passe bien et il appelait la faune en
général s'adaptent très très bien
d'accord la sécheresse pour nous c'est
moins
grave moins pénalisant que l'humilité
quand il pleut on perd on perd une
couveuse en une journée il a plus
l'appeler mouiller les petits sont
mouillés c'est mort donc la saison de
chasse sera sans doute promettent en
tout cas s'annonce prometteuse merci
beaucoup alain blanc obligé de conclure
merci beaucoup merci d'être venus ce
soir sur notre plateau